la monalisa y su icónica sonrisa
cubierta de crema chantilly en el museo
de luz un hombre de 36 años disfrazado
de mujer mayor saltó de una silla de
ruedas y en valor 9 pastel el cuadro
mientras instaba a la gente a pensar en
el planeta piensa en la tierra hay gente
que está destruyendo la tierra los
testigos describieron el suceso como
inimaginable y las redes sociales se
llenaron de imágenes gracias a su
carcasa de cristal la pieza quedó
intacta y el autor fue escoltado por
guardias de seguridad hay una
investigación en curso pero no es la
primera vez que la obra más famosa de
leonardo davinci sufre un ataque en 1956
fue puesta tras un cristal cuando un
estudiante boliviano lanzó una piedra
contra el cuadro dañando su cuadro
izquierdo en 2009 un turista ruso le
lanzó una taza de té rayando la cubierta
el famoso cuadro fue noticia cuando fue
robado en 1911 con el poeta francés
guillaume apollinaire y el pintor
español pablo picasso entre los
sospechosos
finalmente atrapado dos años después
habiendo cometido el robo disfrazado de
obrero el día del cierre
[Música]